I'm going to tell you about the greatest
brand deal of all time Air Jordans so
Michael Jordan signed a deal in 1984 for
$2.5 million $500,000 a year and 5% of
Revenue of anything that used his
likeness like shoes and the reason Nike
was willing to do that was because they
were trying to break into the basketball
category the reason it's been such a
landmark deal is because now fast
forward 40 years later Jordan's did 5
something billion dollar and he still
got 5% of top line so $250 million in
royalty checks than one on Michael
Jordan you have two options as a
business owner to use the strategy that
Nike Dead one you can create your own
personal brand that then you endorse
some product and say hey grab my nose
strips or you can go find other people
who have brands that you have Affinity
with who embody the values that you want
to associate your brand with it's one of
the highest leverage ways that you can
sell things at a huge premium and get
raving fans that will never move away as
long as you continue to espouse those
values